After the birth of Jane Ives, the telekinetically
powered girl commonly known as Eleven, in
1971, Dr. Martin Brenner could only perform
limited experiments until she was old enough
to perform some larger tests. These tests
are what led her to interacting with the Demogorgon
in roughly 1983, but it’s history may go
much deeper than what we see on screen.
The Demogorgon is an other-worldly creature,
so to understand it we’re going to look
at how it’s form was inspired by the beasts
of our world, and analyze it’s story seen
in Stranger Things and the Stranger Things
comic series. I’ll also be exploring what
really happened to the Demogorgon, and the
hidden connection it shares with Eleven so
stick around to the end of this video to hear
all about it.
This video is sponsored by Raycon.
(chaotic piano)
The Demogorgon is a monster from an alternate
dimension that spent its life in darkness
and decay; stalking around the area referred
to as Mirkwood to find its next meal before
slipping back behind the curtain that separates
its cold abyss from our own dimension. Welcome
to Horror History -- in this video I’ll
just be covering the being known as The Demogorgon,
and in future videos I’ll go over other
members of the Demogorgon species. It’s
kind of like how in Alien we have the Xenomorph,
who is also part of the Xenomorph species.
The actual name of The Demogorgon (or it’s
species) is not known, the characters just
come up with that name based on this Demon
Prince character from the game they’re playing,
Dungeons and Dragons, which may be partially
based off of the forbidden primeval god from
Ancient Greek mythology.
Not much is known about the Demogorgon prior
to its appearance in Hawkins, however in analyzing
what the Demogorgon truly represents and embodies
to the community of Hawkins, we have to take
this all the way back to the 1940s. ROLL THE
HORROR HISTORY SCREEN.
(old timey-piano)
With the Cold War spanning the majority of
the 20th Century, Americans were generally
concerned about communism spreading through
their communities and the government. This
eventually led to McCarthyism and Truman’s
Loyalty Program in an attempt to curb the
worries of the citizens. McCarthyism was a
campaign from 1950-1954 that was run by Senator
Joseph McCarthy, who claimed there were communists
hiding in plain sight in the US Government,
along with other major institutions. It’s
basically like how there are people who are
subscribed to this channel, but they don’t
have the deathbell on, like I know you’re
out there. And I WILL FIND YOU.
McCarthyism devolved into basically an early
version of cancel culture where people who
maybe weren’t communist ended up on blacklists
and sometimes lost their jobs. So The Truman
Loyalty Program was made to root out communists
and prevent them from entering government
positions but you’re probably wondering
what the FRICK this has to do with old flowerface
over here -- I swear, I’m getting to that.
So you may remember in Season 3, semi-spoiler
alert for Season 3 I guess, that the kids discover
a whole Russian communist operation hidden
underneath the town. But the original Demogorgon
and the experiments at Hawkins lab served
as a more covert symbol for the communist
agenda way back in the first season. I don’t
know why I’m saying way, back as if it was
that long ago.
So anyway, the US Central Intelligence Agency
was disturbed and intrigued by prisoners of
war coming back from The Korean War and talking
about communist propaganda, and they believed
this could be a form of Russian mind control,
so they launched project MK-ULTRA in April
of 1953. Despite how it sounds, this was no
electronic music festival. They used certain
active substances to try make advancements
in mind control to combat Russia.
In Stranger Things, the Hawkins National Lab
uses MK Ultra to explain how Eleven might
have obtained her psychokinetic abilities
-- it’s suggested through her mother’s
participation in secret experiments that continued
on past the initial end of MK-ULTRA, which
was sometime in 1973. You can actually see
MK-ULTRA included in part of an article title
in a newspaper story about Hawkins Laboratory
that Hopper finds in the library. This article
is potentially from around 1975, which is
when some details of the project were initially
released to the public.
So the fear of trouble in Hawkins that arises
when residents start going missing, is akin
the hysteria that swept America during the
communist scare lasting until the USSR dissolved
in the early 90s.
It’s been suggested that the Demogorgon
is the Upside-Down version of El, seeing as
how they are the only ones of their kind so
far to exhibit telekinesis. There are other
examples, which we’ll get to...
Eleven was born in ‘71, but Dr. Brenner
held larger tests that led her to interaction
with the Demogorgon in roughly 1983. Her first
“encounter” with it is when she’s sent
telepathically to listen to a Russian man’s
conversation. We don’t see the Demogorgon
in this scene however, we are able to hear
its screech, or is it a roar? This could be
because Eleven and the Demogorgon are linked,
and its scream is because it shares the same
fear that she holds being forced into the
deprivation tank. The scream sounds like a
cross between a dinosaur and a slowed down
orangutan.
(orangutan calls)
(Demogorgon cry)
It also sounds a little bit like me whenever
I get put on hold.
- [Automated Voice] All representatives are currently assisting other customers. Please stay on the line.
- (ROAR)
Eleven is encouraged by Brenner to face the
monster she saw again by diving back into
the sensory deprivation tanks. When she does
find it, the Demogorgon feeds on what looks
like either a giant egg, similar to the one
seen in the Upside-Down, or a tree stump covered
in sap.
Only when she touches its back is when it
finally acknowledges her and lets out a massive…
roar?
- [Automated voice] We're sorry. All of our representatives are still busy.
- (ROAR)
This scares Eleven back into our reality once
she’s met with the Demogorgon’s face,
which opens like a series of flower petals
resembling a squid’s tentacles opening to
engulf its prey. The Demogorgon has a series
of sharp canines while squids have sharp rings
on their clubbed tentacles, to help grip their
prey to effectively rip it apart. The comparison
holds up in later scenes, where we see the
Demogorgon eating in a similar style... including
the squid’s tendency to start eating prey
while it’s still alive like one of those
Korean Mukbang chicks.
The next time the Demogorgon appears is when
the gate between the Upside-Down and our dimension
is opened on November 6th, 1983. It takes
this chance to hunt everyone in the lab that
it can locate. We can assume it devoured as
much as it could in this short timespan in
a similar way to how some carnivores engage
in what is known as opportunity hunting, for
example, you’ll see Bears do this, because
they need to quickly gain enough weight for
hibernation.
The Demogorgon, could share a similar mentality
since fresh food is usually a limited resource
for it in the Upside-Down, which is mainly
void of other lifeforms. You’ll also notice
Eleven also has to relieve her hunger around
this time, but her victims come in the form
of Eggo waffles.
Rather than returning to the Upside-Down,
the flowerface becomes the enemy in the shadows
and begins roaming the woods around town for
fresh prey. It specifically stays in the same
area Will and his friends call ‘Mirkwood’
. The area it stays in is small because it’s
the closest area to the portal and because
it’s the same area that Will is hiding in
in the Upside-Down.
On the surface, Hawkins is your standard,
small-town America where nothing really happens
and everyone is somewhat familiar with each
other. It’s 1983 and most of the families
we see are the typical ‘Nuclear Family’.
The Cold War frequently comes up in conversation,
usually through the references of Russian
“commies” or “communists”. While Hawkins
doesn’t stand out as being special and is
meant to be the stereotypical small town from
the 80s, it does highlight the nagging sense
of anxiety that anyone around you could be
a communist below the surface.
For the residents, life is fairly simple with
lines being drawn to distinguish what is considered
normal and what is not. Things that are “not
normal” are frequently met with criticism
and disbelief, which reflects on the mentality
during the Cold War where Americans were on
high alert about potential communists.
This is reflected in how the town treats certain
families. The Byers’ live in a secluded
area that’s just outside of town and Joyce
is divorced. Despite having two kids and a
dog, they don’t fit the standard white picket
fence idea of a perfect family. The series
even opens with a peek into how their lifestyle
is not-so-average. With it, Jonathan has taken
an almost father-like role, while also trying
to be Will’s older brother.
Then we have the Wheeler family. They serve
as what is considered the typical nuclear
family. Nancy describes her parents’ marriage
as her mother marrying well, finding the perfect
house at the end of a cul-de-sac, and raising
the perfect family in the perfect house.
- I don't think my parents ever loved each other.
- They must have married for some reason.
- My Mom was young.
My Dad was older. And he had a cushy job.
Money. Came from a good family.
So they bought a nice house at the end of the cul-de-sac.
And started their nuclear family.
- Then she perfectly shoots a can when she’s
never handled a gun before, the same way she
gets everything right on her flashcards.
On the night of November 6th, Will Byers is
going home after a D&D campaign with his friends,
and cuts through Mirkwood. This is when The
Demogorgon comes after Will, and the lights
flicker as he runs from it. We don’t see
the monster in this scene, but we can hear
it screeching in the night. This could potentially
be it using sound in a similar way to how
bats use sonar waves to detect objects in
order to navigate through the dark, since
the Demogorgon doesn’t appear to have eyes.
Nancy and Jonathan also later determine that
the Demogorgon hunts by tracking blood, similar
to a shark.
When it catches up with him, The Demogorgon
is able to warp Will into the Upside-Down
by weakening the fabric between the dimensions,
and like a shark, the creature closes in on
it’s meal.
(impact)
I can't believe how long it's been since we
did one with Raycon. I actually still have
my original pair that they sent me over 2
years ago. They still work, but I like the
black ones, gotta stay on brand.
I'm using these things all the time during
my workouts and runs. For some reason, other
brands don't really make these things ear-shaped,
so they just fall out, but Raycons stay in
thanks to their optimized gel tips.
The new Everyday Earbuds offer an improved
rubber oil look and feel
With 8 hours of playtime you can listen to
the first 12 Weezer albums in one sitting
and thanks to the charging case, you 32-hours
of battery life overall.
There’s also a built-in mic and you can
take calls at the press of a button. Hold
on.
Oh, hey PewDiePie. Yeah, I'm recording a Raycon
ad right now, I'll help you with your content
strategy stuff a bit later. Alright later.
Raycons start at half the price of other premium
audio brands, but they sound just as good
and come with a 45-day happiness guarantee.
EEEE
You already know what to do. Click the link
in the description box or go to buyraycon.com/czsworld
to unlock exclusive deals up to 20-percent
off your Raycon order! buyraycon.com/czsworld
(mysterious music)
After chasing the Demogorgon off by firing
the gun, Will wanders around the Upside-Down’s
version of his house where he struggles to
communicate with his mom, or anyone from the
top side. Will explores the distorted version
of his house, and eventually falls asleep
beneath the Jaws poster in his mock-room,
maybe a clue about the creature’s blood
sensing abilities.
Back on the surface, the town itself is temporarily
thrown into a seemingly lack-luster disarray
when it’s announced that Will Byers went
missing on his way home. Even Police Chief
Hopper initially takes the information almost
light-heartedly when Joyce includes the detail
that Will is a target of bullying at school,
along with Will’s father calling him
- ...a queer. Said he was a f*g.
- This line of questioning, along with Joyce
begging Hopper to believe her, can parallel
a representation of Truman’s Loyalty Policies.
These insist that people should trust the
government to do what was necessary to keep
communism out of their neighborhoods. It’s
only after Joyce answers Hopper’s questions
that he appears more interested in the case.
Unfortunately for Hawkins, the monster that
infiltrated their town is far more than a
communist. The Demogorgon’s presence shows
the nature of the hysteria involved with speculating
that there is a communist hiding next door.
We can get a grasp on this representation
by using aspects from the first chapter of
Jeffery Cohen’s Monster Theory, along with
a historical perspective. The book presents
seven theses, each involving various creatures
being a symbolic representation of the cultures
that created them. For the infiltration of
Hawkins, we can refer to thesis number four,
where monsters are embodiments of what’s
different. Cohen writes that the creature
can be a form of “the Other” and in this
case, that “Other” is the Russians.
When Will wakes up to find himself still trapped
in the Upside-down, he tries to communicate
with his mom. The activity ends up attracting
the Demogorgon back to him as a form of connection
is established through his Supercomm. Luckily,
Will manages to scare the Demogorgon off a
second time by shooting at it but uses the
last of the ammunition.
Meanwhile, search parties continue combing
the woods for Will, but his friends are not
content with sitting at home doing nothing.
Eleven tries to explain where Will is by flipping
their D&D board over and placing Will’s
Wizard token in the center.
- Hiding.
- From the bad man?
- [Gordon] There’s no such thing as the bad man.
- Shut up Gordon, you don’t show up till Season
3. El places the Demogorgon token next to
Will’s Wizard piece. This explains how they
come to associate the name Demogorgon with
the monster, a name that sticks from then
on. I’ve also seen it suggested that the
Demogorgon token having two heads could be
a potential clue about duality if, in fact,
The Demogorgon is the Upside-Down version
of Eleven.
On Tuesday night, Nancy Wheeler brings her
friend Barb to a party at Steve Harrington’s
house. Barb ends up sitting by the pool after
cutting her hand and a blood drop falls into
the water, which is likely what drew the Demogorgon
to her. It appears behind her, as seen in
Jonathan Byers’s photographs, and brings
her into the Upside-Down.
Barb’s screams echo through the Upside-Down
as she’s dragged down into the empty pool
by the Demogorgon. Will, who is still in hiding
there can hear her screams, along with the
Demogorgon’s cry, and he runs out towards
the screams in an attempt to help her.
But -- he’s too late, Will returns to the
Upside-Down version of his home and is able
to talk to his mom again, but also draws the
Demogorgon’s attention again. This time,
it goes for Mrs. Byers by ripping a hole in
the wall Andy Bernard style. It seems to be
able to sense where the veil between the worlds
is thinner, and it will prioritize getting
more people rather than always taking care
of the easiest target. I mean, it’s obviously
to make the show more dramatic… but if I
had to give it a logical reason… uh yeah,
let’s go with that thing I said. We see
a similar scene later on, this time Will takes
his Mom’s advice and runs for it.
Then, in the underground lab, a scientist
explores the Upside-Down, communicating via
the microphone in his suit. He is basically
the Demogorgon equivalent of that light up
sign at Krispy Kreme that says hot donuts.
When the other scientists desperately try
to pull him back, they end up with just some
spine and ribcage tied to the chain that was
around his waist. Hey, at least the food’s
not going to waste.
Since the Demogorgon has infiltrated Hawkins
from the Upside-Down, it’s easy to say that
the Upside-Down itself is the equivalent of
the Iron Curtain. The Iron Curtain was an
implied wall in Europe that separated areas
controlled by the Soviet Union from Western
Allies.
Those who crossed over to the Soviet side
of the curtain in the mid-80s may be greeted
with floating particles of ash similar to
those seen in the Upside-Down, because that’s
exactly what happened after the Chernobyl
disaster in 1986, when a reactor melted
down and forced evacuations for hundreds of
miles around the city of Pripyat.
This could also explain why the Upside-Down
is mostly deserted, other than this strange
mutated creature. These attributes could also
be related to a meltdown in Three Mile Island
in Pennsylvania in the US, which was designed
to compete with the Russain advances in nuclear
technology.
Just as Godzilla rose from Japan in the fallout
of their nuclear disaster -- history itself
can become the monster, and events of days
past can turn fears of contamination into
the horrors on your TV screen, or whatever
the **** you watch this show on.
Nancy and Jonathan decide to hunt down the
Demogorgon in the woods. They stumble across
a dying deer, but before putting it out of
its misery…
...it’s abruptly yeeted back into the bushes.
Nancy ends up following the red trail through
a portal at the base of a tree and discovers
the Demogorgon… well, we’ve all seen someone
do this at the local discount buffet right?
It uses its squid-like face to rip its meal
to pieces, not even realizing that there are
other patrons, at the buffet.
However, when the Demogorgon does realize
Nancy is there, it chases her into hiding
and traps her by blocking the portal back
to the real world, which tells us that the
monster does have some intelligence. Nancy
hears Jonathan’s voice calling from the
other side of the tree portal, which seems
to be closing, but Nancy isn’t the only
one who hears him. Will is also close enough
to hear his brother and ends up finding Nancy,
along with the portal, and the Demogorgon.
Instead of going for the portal himself, Will
distracts the Demogorgon with a rock so Nancy
can escape. The Demogorgon takes the next
easy meal; the hunter, Henry, who had also
recently been trapped in the Upside-Down.
Exhausted and beginning to hallucinate, Will
goes to the last safe place he can think of:
Castle Byers. Unfortunately for him, it’s
not as safe as he believes.
(impact)
(synth music)
As Will lays in his fort, Castle Byers, Eleven
visits him psycho-kinetically to tell him
that his mother is coming for him and to hold
on a little while longer. After she vanishes, Will
starts muttering the lyrics to his favorite
The Clash song (OK Will, I see you) but unfortunately,
so does the Demogorgon, sending it straight
to his location.
If Eleven and the Demogorgon are linked, it
stands to reason that when Eleven found Will,
she accidentally tipped off his location.
Basically anything she knows, the Demogorgon
knows, and this happens multiple times. We
see a similar concept with Will and the Mindflayer
in Season 2.
It seems to be implied that Will is unable
to escape this time, but our friend flowerface
has bigger plans for him than simply making
him a midnight snack. Will finds himself deep
within the creature’s nest, with some kind
of facehugging organism plastered to his mouth.
I’m guessing this is because Will is so
small that the Demogorgon would prefer to
make him a carrier rather than a meal. The
slug implanted within him appears to be the
Demogorgon’s offspring.
I don’t know if that makes the Demogorgon
the male or the female, and I don’t really
want to think about it, so let’s just skip
to Nancy and Jonathan setting up the trap
on Friday, the 11th. They end up cutting their
own palms to lure it back to them with the
smell of their blood.
However, the monster is too powerful, and
knocks Jonathan down while surviving every
bullet Nancy has in her gun… which kind
of begs the question why it was afraid of
Will’s gun earlier on, but maybe it was
just a case of the creature not knowing its
own power -- like how if you tie down an elephant
with a small rope, it won’t realize it can
escape.
Just before it’s about to strike Nancy,
Steve Harrington rushes in, and using the
nailed bat and starts taking it to the monster
Kris Bryant style. The three of them manage
to get the monster’s foot stuck in the bear
trap and light it on fire. As Jonathan puts
the flames out, they find the beast gone with
only the dissolving remnants of flesh clinging
to the trap, presumably having been driven
back to its own dimension.
While Chief Hopper and Will’s mom are rescuing
him from the Upside-Down, Dr. Brenner and
his people storm the school to try to kidnap
Eleven. She uses her abilities to squeeze
the brains of all the “Bad Men” threatening
her friends, but the use of her powers once
again causes a nose bleed and attracts the
Demogorgon. The kids run to try and get to
safety in the science classroom.
The boys scream for Lucas to get the wrist
rocket out as the Demogorgon breaks down the
door, following the scent of Eleven’s blood.
While the rocks don’t actually do much damage,
Eleven recovers just enough to send the monster
flying back into the wall and, with a parting
farewell, proceeds to disintegrate the Demogorgon,
disappearing into the Upside-down herself
as she does so.
It’s very interesting how when they come
face to face, they are practically mirror
images of each other, and the only way for
El to defeat it, or get rid of it, also hurts
her and transports her to the upside down.
This isn’t proof that she’s the Demogorgon
and the Demogorgon is her, but I can’t ignore
the fact that she sees herself as the monster.
- El!
- [Eleven] Mike. I’m sorry.
- Sorry? What are you sorry for?
- The gate. I opened it. I’m the monster.
- So if El is the Demogorgon, and she survives
this battle, seemingly being transported back
into the Upside-Down it’s possible that
old flowerface survives too, just as the idea
of communism has somehow survived many wars
over many years.
Or, it could just be that the creature seen
in Russia at the end of the third season is
just another member of the same species. Either
way, the analogy probably stands.
If you want to see the histories of more horror
monsters, click that playlist on the left.
We’ve got more Stranger Things episodes
coming, so remember to subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week, ring the deathbell
for notifications and I’ll see you in the
next one. Assuming we both survive.